قال المبعوث الامريكي الخاص لايراننا
روبرت شمالي ان الدبلوماسيه خيار واشنطن
الاول لمنع طهران من امتلاكه سلاح النووي
اضافه في مقابله مع موقع فورم بوليسيه ان
الخيار العسكري لازاله على الطاوله كخيار
الاخير في حال فشل العقوبات الدبلوماسيه
انها الطريقه الافضل والاكثر استدامه لمنع
ايران من امتلاكه سلاح النووي ولا تزال
الدبلوماسيه خيارنا الافضل ونقوم باستخدام
خيارات اخرى من بينها الضغط الدولي الذي
لم تختبره ايران لسنوات عديده فلدينا
العقوبات والضغوط الدبلوماسيه واذا لم
تنجح اي من تلك الادوات قال الرئيس انه قد
يوافق على الخيار العسكري كخيار الاخير
لكننا لم نصل الى تلك المرحله ومازلنا
نامل ان نجد وسائل اخرى وان تغير ايران
مسارها الحالي